you told Tim Ferriss that the perfect
day is caffeine for 10 hours and alcohol
for four hours
you didn't think I'd be mentioning this
did you uh it balances everything out
perfectly as you said uh so let me ask
what's what's the secret to balance and
maybe to happiness in life
um I I don't believe in Balance so I
when I'm with the wrong person asking
can you elaborate why you don't believe
in Balance I mean I I maybe it's just
and I I look I think people I think
people are wired differently so I think
it's hard to generalize uh this kind of
thing but I'm much happier and more
satisfied when I'm fully committed to
something so I'm very much in favor of
it of imbalance yeah
imbalance and that applies to work to
life to everything
now now I happen to have whatever Twist
of personality traits lead that in
non-destructive Dimensions including the
fact that I've actually I now no longer
do the 10-4 plan I stopped drinking I do
the caffeine but not the alcohol so
there's something in my personality
where I I whatever maladaption I have is
inclining me towards productive things
not unproductive things so you're one of
the wealthiest people in the world
what's the relationship between wealth
and happiness oh uh money and happiness
so I think happiness
I don't think happiness is the thing to
strive for I think satisfaction is the
thing
that's that just sounds like happiness
but turned down a bit no deeper so
happiness is you know a walk in the
woods at Sunset an ice cream cone a kiss
um the first ice cream cone is great the
thousandth ice cream cone
not so much at some point the walks in
the woods get boring what's the
distinction between happiness and uh
satisfaction satisfaction is a deeper
thing which is like having found a
purpose and fulfilling it being useful
so just uh something that permeates all
your days just this General contentment
of
of being useful then I'm fully
satisfying my faculties that I'm fully
delivering right on the gifts that I've
been given that I'm you know net making
the world better that I'm contributing
to the people around me
right and that I can look back and say
wow that was hard but it was worth it
I think generally seems to lead people
in a better State than pursuit of
pleasure pursuit of quote unquote
happiness does money have anything to do
with that I think the founders of the
founding fathers in the US threw this
off kilter when they use the phrase
Pursuit of Happiness I think they should
have said
pursuit of satisfaction we might live in
a better world today well you know they
could have elaborated in a lot of things
they could have tweaked the Second
Amendment I think they were smarter than
they realized they said you know what
we're going to make it ambiguous and let
these uh these humans figure out the
rest these tribal cult-like humans
figure out the rest
uh but money empowers that so I I think
and I think there I mean look I think
Elon is I don't think I'm even a great
example but I think Elon would be the
great example of this which is like you
know look he's a guy who from every
every day of his life from the day he
started making money at all he just
plows into the into the next thing
um and so I think I think money is
definitely an enabler for satisfaction
it was supposed to say money applied to
happiness leads people down very dark
paths
very destructive Avenues uh money
applied to satisfaction I think could be
is a real tool
um I always by the way I was like you
know Elon is the case study for Behavior
but the other thing that it's always
really made me think is Larry Larry Page
was asked one time what his approach to
philanthropy was and he said oh I'm just
my my philanthropic plan is just give
all the money to Elon